It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在正值盛花期，我的业务发展迅速。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有极速优先数据的手机套餐。这就是我选择Google Fi Wireless的原因。即使蜂房里人声鼎沸，我的连接依然强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月35美元起。这绝对是一个不会常有的优惠。立即探索Google Fi Wireless套餐。需另付税费和政府规费。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. For many people, the stereotype of adult life might include a house with a picket fence and 2.5 children. But in the United States, a growing number of adults are saying that they're happy to do without the kids' part of that vision. A 2021 Pew Research Center poll found that 44% of non-parents, ages 18 to 49, said it was unlikely that they would have children in the future, up from 37% in 2018. When asked why, more than half said that they just didn't want to have kids. Despite these significant numbers, until recently not much research had looked specifically at people who choose not to have children, sometimes called child-free adults. Instead, researchers often lump child-free adults in with a larger pool
Google Fi Wireless在网络高流量期间不会受到数据流量优先权降低的影响。对很多人来说，成年生活的刻板印象可能包括一栋带栅栏的房子和2.5个孩子。但在美国，越来越多成年人表示他们很高兴不需要愿景中的孩子部分。皮尤研究中心2021年的一项民意调查发现，在18至49岁无孩子的群体中，44%的人表示他们未来不太可能会生孩子，高于2018年的37%。当被问及原因时，超过一半的人表示他们只是不想生孩子。尽管人数显著，但直到最近，并没有多少研究专门针对那些选择不生孩子的群体（有时被称为丁克成年人）进行探讨。相反，研究人员经常将丁克成年人与更大规模的人群归为一类
of people who were childless for other reasons. Now some researchers are beginning to study this group. They're asking questions such as how common is it to be child-free? What percentage of the population is choosing not to have kids? Do people who decide not to have children early in life stick with that decision, or do they often change their minds? Do child-free adults differ from those who have kids in terms of personality or other characteristics? And what about outcomes? Are people who choose not to have kids happier, less happy, or no different from those who do?
因为其他原因没有孩子的人。现在，一些研究人员开始研究这个群体。他们提出了诸如丁克有多普遍？人口中有多少比例选择不生孩子？在人生早期决定不生孩子的人会坚持这个决定，还是经常改变主意？丁克成年人在性格或其他特征上与有孩子的群体有何不同？结果又如何呢？选择不生孩子的人是否比有孩子的人更快乐、更不快乐，还是没有区别？
What challenges in stigma do child-free adults face and what challenges are there in studying this group? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Jennifer Watling-Neil, a professor in the Social and Personality Psychology Program at Michigan State University. For the past several years, she, along with her colleague in Hunt, husband, Dr. Zachary Neal, have been studying adults who choose not to have children, who they are, what they're like, and how they're treated by others. In addition to her research on child-free
丁克成年人面临什么样的污名挑战？研究这个群体又面临什么挑战？欢迎收听《心理学说话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是密歇根州大学社会与人格心理学项目的教授詹妮弗·沃特林·尼尔博士。在过去的几年里，她和她的丈夫兼同事扎卡里·尼尔博士一直在研究选择不生孩子的成年人：他们是谁，他们是什么样的人，以及他们如何受到他人的对待。除了对丁克的研究外
adults, Dr. Neal also studies how kids' peer networks shape their behavior, personality, and well-being. Dr. Neal's research on child-free adults has been covered by the Wall Street Journal, NPR, and The Today Show, among other media outlets. Dr. Neal, I want to thank you for joining me today. Thanks, Kim. I'm so excited to be here talking about our research on child-free adults with you today. I mentioned in the introduction that researchers often lump child-free adults in with a larger group of people who don't have children for other reasons. So let's start with your definition. What is child-free in your research and how did you choose to use that term as opposed to something else? Sure. That's a great question. So we know from past research that a lot of folks sort of lump all
尼尔博士还研究同伴网络如何塑造儿童的行为、个性与福祉。尼尔博士关于丁克成年人的研究已被《华尔街日报》、《全国公共广播电台》和《今日秀》等各大媒体报道。尼尔博士，我想感谢你今天能来参加节目。谢谢，金。我很高兴今天能来和你一起讨论我们对丁克成年人的研究。我在引言中提到，研究人员经常把丁克成年人与因其他原因没有孩子的大群体归为一类。那么让我们从你的定义开始。在你的研究中，“丁克（无孩子）”是什么意思？你为什么选择这个词而不是其他词？当然。这是一个很好的问题。所以我们从过去的研究中了解到，许多人往往把所有
non-parents together. But non-parents are really a heterogeneous group. And child-free adults are a particular type of non-parent. They're people that don't have any kids and they don't want to have any kids. So they're different from folks who are planning to have children in the future. In our research, we refer to those folks as not yet parents, different from folks who are undecided. Maybe they're not sure whether they want to have kids in the future or not. And they're different from childless people. So childless people are people who don't have kids, but really wanted to have children. Maybe they couldn't have them due to social or medical circumstances. Now, you've done two large studies looking at the prevalence of being child-free among adults in Michigan. What percentage of that
非父母群体归为一类。但非父母实际上是一个异质群体。而丁克成年人是一类特殊的非父母。他们是指没有任何孩子并且不想生任何孩子的人。所以他们不同于那些计划在未来生孩子的人。在我们的研究中，我们将这些人称为“尚未为人父母者”，这与那些“尚未决定”的人不同。也许他们不确定自己未来是否想要孩子。他们也不同于“无子女”的人。因此，“无子女”的人是指没有孩子，但非常渴望拥有孩子的人。也许他们因为社会或医疗情况而无法生育。现在，你做了两项大型研究，调查了密歇根州成年人中无子女现象的普遍程度。这一比例是多少？
population is child-free? What else did you find? Yeah. So in our research, we looked at a representative sample of adults in Michigan. And we found that between 20 and 25% of Michigan adults are child free. That means that they didn't have kids. And they also expressed that they didn't want to have children in the future. And that was quite a large number. We weren't necessarily expecting to find such a large number of child free folks in Michigan. Did they give any indication as to why they were child free? Yeah. So in our study, unfortunately, we didn't have questions in those surveys. about the reasons for being child-free. But in other studies, there have been lots of studies
人群中有多少比例是丁克的？你们还发现了什么？是的。在我们的研究中，我们调查了密歇根州成年人的一个代表性样本。我们发现，密歇根州20%到25%的成年人是丁克。这意味着他们没有孩子。并且他们也表示未来不想要孩子。这是一个相当大的数字。我们不一定预料到密歇根州会有这么大比例的丁克人群。他们有没有说明为什么选择丁克？是的。所以在我们的研究中，不幸的是，这些调查中没有关于成为丁克原因的问题。但在其他研究中，有很多研究
that have looked at this question of why people are child-free, and they often give a wide range of reasons. So it could be the high cost of having children, restrictions on freedom or on career growth, medical risks and restrictions on reproductive freedom, climate change, the whole host of things, maybe political forces as well. But as you mentioned in your introduction, one of the most common reasons people give, they found in that 2021 Pew study, is that people just don't want to have children.
探讨了人们为什么选择丁克这个问题，他们通常会给出广泛的原因。比如养育孩子的成本高昂、对自由或职业发展的限制、健康风险以及对生育自由的限制、气候变化、各种各样的因素，可能还有政治力量。但正如你在引言中提到的，人们给出的最常见原因之一（他们在2021年的皮尤研究中发现）是人们根本不想生孩子。
How representative do you think your study was of the U.S. as a whole? That's a really good question. So, of course, our research is only focused on adults in Michigan. However, we do not that Michigan's population is similar to the general U.S. population in terms of age, race, education. income and politics. So we believe that our findings might apply more broadly. And if that pattern that we were finding holds up nationally, it would mean about 50 to 60 million Americans are child free. Do you have any plans to do national level follow-up research? We're very interested in doing national-level follow-up research. So one of the things that we've been doing lately is looking at
你认为你的研究对整个美国有多大代表性？这是一个非常好的问题。当然，我们的研究仅关注密歇根州的成年人。不过，我们确实注意到密歇根州的人口在年龄、种族、教育程度、收入和政治倾向方面与美国总体人口相似。因此，我们相信我们的研究结果可能适用于更广泛的范围。如果我们在全国范围内发现的这种模式成立，那就意味着大约5000万到6000万美国人是丁克。你们是否有计划进行全国范围的后续研究？我们对进行全国范围的后续研究非常感兴趣。所以我们最近一直在做的事情之一就是寻找
existing population representative data sets that are available where we could really identify, child free people and distinguish them from other parents. So one such survey is from the Center for Disease Control. It's called the National Survey of Family Growth. They have questions about whether people have children and whether people want children. So we're looking more carefully at that data set, as well as some other data sets in the U.S. and in other countries. Is there any historical data around this? I mean, do we know about change over time? Yeah. So the National Survey for Family Growth has data that's been collected over time. It goes back to the 80s, actually, in 1980s, but the data sets are kind of easy to obtain publicly from 2002. So we're sort of looking
现有的具有人口代表性的可用数据集，在这些数据集中，我们真的可以识别出丁克人群，并将他们与其他父母区分开来。其中一个这样的调查来自疾病控制中心。它被称为“全美家庭增长调查”。他们调查了人们是否有孩子以及人们是否想要孩子。因此，我们正在更仔细地研究该数据集，以及美国和世界其他地方的一些其他数据集。这方面有任何历史数据吗？我的意思是，我们了解随时间的变化吗？是的。所以全美家庭增长调查有随时间收集的数据。实际上可以追溯到80年代，即1980年代，但这些数据集从2002年起比较容易公开获取。所以我们现在基本上是从
from 2002 now all the way up to 2019 and trying to look at prevalence rates in that data set. How likely are child-free adults, especially younger adults, to change their mind? So people who say that they're child-free when they're in their 20s, do they end? up having kids when they're 30 or 40, or do they tend to make the decision and stick with it? Yeah, this is an outstanding question. So in our data, we were really focused on data sets in Michigan that were cross-sectional. So of course, we couldn't kind of track over time to see if people were actively changing their mind. But one of the things that we did do in these surveys, we asked what age people made the decision to be child-free at? And we found that most child-free
2002年一直看到2019年，并试图研究该数据集中的流行率。丁克成年人（尤其是年轻成年人）改变主意的可能性有多大？那么，那些在20多岁时说自己是丁克的人，最后会在30多岁或40多岁时生孩子吗？还是他们往往做出决定并坚持下去？是的，这是一个极好的问题。在我们的数据中，我们真正关注的是密歇根州的横断面数据集。所以，当然，我们无法随时间追踪人们是否在积极改变主意。但我们在这些调查中做的一件事是，询问人们是在什么年龄决定成为丁克的？我们发现大多数丁克
people decided that they did not want children at an early age. They were reporting that they decided that they didn't want children usually in their teens or 20s. And these are people who were on average now about 45 years old and were still child free. So you have to take it a little bit with a grain of salt because it's cross-sectional data. People could be misremembering when they decided. But if we kind of take what they're saying in these surveys, it's suggesting that people decide in early age and they're not likely to kind of change their mind. The mind changing is not particularly common. Do men and women give the same reasons for being child free?
人们在很小的时候就决定不想要孩子。他们报告说，他们通常在十几岁或二十多岁时决定不想要孩子。而这些人现在平均年龄在45岁左右，仍然是丁克。所以你必须对这些结果持保留态度，因为这是横断面数据。人们可能会记错他们决定的时间。但如果我们采纳他们在这些调查中所说的话，这就表明人们在很小的时候就做出了决定，并且不太可能改变主意。改变主意并不是特别常见。男人和女人成为丁克的原因是一样的吗？
That's a good question. I'm not sure that I know the answer to that. A lot of the studies on child free reasons are qualitative studies, many of them have tended to focus on women as a population's fewer studies out there on men. But I think in that the Pew study, I think the most common reason across men and women, if I'm remembering correctly, was this just, I just don't want to have kids. Now, you found a significant drop in the number of Michigan adults who wanted to have children after the Supreme Court's decision in the Dobbs versus Jackson case, and that's the case that overturned the constitutional right to abortion. Do you believe that Dobbs was a deciding factor for some people? And if so, why? Yeah, we don't know for certain.
这是一个好问题。我不确定我是否知道答案。关于丁克原因的许多研究都是定性研究，其中许多研究倾向于将女性作为人口来关注，关于男性的研究较少。但我认为在皮尤研究中，如果我没记错的话，无论男女，最常见的原因就是“我只是不想生孩子”。现在，在最高法院对“多布斯诉杰克逊案”作出裁决后，你发现密歇根州想要孩子的成年人数量显着下降，该案推翻了堕胎的宪法权利。你认为多布斯案是某些人的决定性因素吗？如果是，为什么？是的，我们无法确定。
we did find this significant drop-in people. Actually, we found a significant growth in people who are identifying as child-free. So it was really interesting. We were collecting data in Michigan pre-Dobbs, and then we were continuing to collect data post-Dobbs. So basically, in 2022, when the Roe v. Wade was overturned by Dobbs v. Jackson, there was sort of significant confusion in Michigan with multiple conflicting court cases about what might happen to abortion rights. So Michigan had a zombie law on the books at that time that outlawed abortion.
我们确实发现人数大幅下降。实际上，我们发现自称为丁克的人数显着增长。所以这真的很有趣。我们在多布斯案之前收集密歇根州的数据，然后我们继续收集多布斯案之后的数据。所以基本上在2022年，当罗诉韦德案被多布斯诉杰克逊案推翻时，密歇根州出现了一种显着的混乱，多起相互冲突的法院案件引发了关于堕胎权可能会发生什么变化的争论。因此当时密歇根州有一项“僵尸法律”将堕胎定为非法。
And there were many kind of conflicting court cases going on where it wasn't, we weren't sure if that law was going to go into place or not. And that's right around the time when we collected multiple waves of data looking at the prevalence of child-free folks. And during that period of confusion, we observed that the number of Michigan adults identifying as child free rose from 21% before the decision. Those were data that were collected in September 2021 and April 2022 to nearly 26% afterwards in September 2020 and December 2020. So it's a really short time span, and we did see this big growth during that time span. We can't say for certain that that was the Dobbs decision that was contributing to that. But I think it possibly could have been. There's definitely other studies that have shown that rates of sterilization, voluntary sterilization, also went up during that period.
并且有许多相互冲突的法院诉讼正在进行，当时我们并不确定该法律是否会生效。正是在那个时候，我们收集了多波数据，观察丁克人群的普及率。在混乱的这段时期，我们观察到自认为丁克的密歇根州成年人比例从决议前的21%上升。这些数据是2021年9月至2022年4月收集的，随后在2020年9月和2020年12月上升到近26%。所以时间跨度很短，我们在那个时间跨度内确实看到了大幅增长。我们不能确定一定是多布斯案促成了这一点。但我想这可能确实是一个原因。绝对有其他研究表明，绝育率、自愿绝育率在那段时期也有所上升。
So there's a sense that when people's reproductive freedoms are taken away, that they might opt out of parenthood. And do you think that maybe had cemented what people were already thinking, just knowing that the option maybe wasn't as easy as it had been previously? Yeah, I do think that that could also be the case. So there could have been people who were child-free, but maybe not kind of identifying so much as it. And when the Dobbs decision came down, it kind of put it in stark relief for them. So they were more likely to identify as child-free after that.
所以有一种感觉，当人们的生育自由被剥夺时，他们可能会选择不为人父母。你认为这是否可能巩固了人们已经有的想法，因为他们知道选择可能不像以前那么容易了？是的，我认为这也是有可能的。所以可能有一些人本来就是丁克，但可能并没有那么强烈的自我认同。当多布斯裁决下达时，这让他们形成了鲜明的对比。因此他们在那之后更有可能认同为丁克。
Have you found significant differences in personality or other characteristics between child-free adults and adults who have children? Yeah, this is a really interesting question. And our very first child-free study in early 2021, we compared life satisfaction, personality, traits, and political ideology of child-free adults to parents and other types of mom-parents. And the interesting thing here is that we found that child-free people look a lot like everybody else with regards to personality, life satisfaction, and political ideology. So, child-free people were just as satisfied with their lives as parents, childless people, or people who are planning to have kids.
你们是否发现丁克成年人和有孩子的成年人在人格或其他特征上有显著差异？是的，这是一个非常有趣的问题。在2021年初我们的第一项丁克研究中，我们将丁克成年人的生活满意度、人格特质和政治意识形态与父母以及其他类型的非父母进行了比较。这里有趣的是，我们发现丁克人群在人格、生活满意度和政治意识形态方面与其他人非常相似。因此，丁克人群对生活的满意度与父母、无子女者或计划生孩子的人一样高。
There were also minimal differences in personality between child-free people and these other groups. We did find that child-free people were slightly more liberal than parents. It's not terribly surprising, but the difference wasn't huge. It wasn't like child-free people were like extremely liberal versus parents. So not a ton of differences. Was that surprising? I mean, you might think that people who tend to hold more traditional views of family would, you know, be more likely to have kids and that those who are a little bit, you know, crunchy granola maybe don't feel the same way.
丁克人群与这些其他群体之间的人格差异也很小。我们确实发现丁克人群比父母略微更倾向于自由派。这并不是特别令人惊讶，但差距并不巨大。丁克人群并不是说极其自由派，而父母则是保守派。所以没有太大的差异。这令人惊讶吗？我的意思是，你可能会认为那些倾向于对家庭持有更传统观点的人（你知道的）更有可能生孩子，而那些（你知道的）有点自然主义倾向的人可能不会有同样的感觉。
Yeah, it's surprising, but it wasn't entirely surprising. I mean, it wasn't super surprising that there weren't personality differences or life satisfaction differences. I think when people make the change, or when people make the decision to be child-free, they are really kind of making the decision that's right for them. And so it's, you know, just like maybe somebody decides they really want to have kids and be a parent. It's the decision that's right for them. So in terms of that, it's not surprising that life satisfaction is not different. In terms of being liberal, we did find a slight difference.
是的，这令人惊讶，但也不是完全出乎意料。我的意思是，没有人格差异或生活满意度差异并不是非常令人惊讶。我认为当人们做出改变，或者当人们做出成为丁克的决定时，他们实际上是在做出适合他们自己的决定。所以，这（你知道的）就像有人决定他们真的很想生孩子并成为父母一样。这是适合他们自己的决定。因此，就这一点而言，生活满意度没有差异并不令人惊讶。在自由派倾向方面，我们确实发现了一点差异。
So we do see sort of this tendency for child-free people to be a little bit more. on the liberal spectrum than a parent who might be a little bit, maybe more conservative. But, yeah, we didn't see this like huge difference in that. What about men versus women? Are more men tending to be child-free than women or vice versa? Do you know? Yeah. So in some of our work, we did find some demographic differences.
所以我们确实看到这种趋势，即丁克人群比可能更倾向于保守的父母更倾向于自由派光谱。但是，是的，我们没有看到这方面有巨大的差异。男性与女性相比呢？是男性更倾向于丁克还是女性，或者反过来？你知道吗？是的。在我们的一些工作中，我们确实发现了一些人口统计学上的差异。
So in our research, more men were child-free than women. So about 23% of men identified as child-free. and only 18% of women. More white individuals identified as child free, almost 23% than people of color. That's around 14%. Not surprisingly, people who have always been single are more likely to identify than child free than people who are married or partnered. So people who are single, 31% identified as child free versus people who were married
所以在我们的研究中，男性丁克比女性多。因此，大约23%的男性自认为是丁克，而女性只有18%。白人自认为是丁克的比例更高，接近23%，而有色人种则约为14%。毫不奇怪，一直单身的人比已婚或有伴侣的人更有可能自认为是丁克。因此，单身人士中有31%自认为是丁克，而已婚或有伴侣的人则为17%。
or partnered 17%. And people who identified as. LGBTQ were more likely to be child-free than adults who did not identify as LGBTQ. You've done some research on stereotypes about child-free adults as well as attitudes that parents have toward child-free adults. What have you found? Is there stigma around being child-free? There is stigma around being child-free. And some qualitative research that's out there has really identified lots of things that child-free people face in their lives because of their decision to be child-free.
自认为是LGBTQ的人比没有自认为是LGBTQ的成年人更有可能成为丁克。你还对关于丁克成年人的刻板印象以及父母对丁克成年人的态度进行了一些研究。你发现了什么？成为丁克是否存在污名？成为丁克确实存在污名。一些现有的定性研究确实指出了丁克人群由于决定成为丁克而在生活中面临的许多事情。
We in the U.S. live in a society where the norm is very much still having children and having children is very valued. So people who do not have children and who also don't want to have children are really sort of going against that norm. And common stereotypes that are mentioned often for child-free people, especially women, that they're selfish, self-centered, that they might be focused on their career, that they have no responsibilities, that they have lots of money, but they hate children, and that they might regret their decision later. So they're really common kinds of stereotypes. We looked at,
在美国，我们生活在一个视生育为常态且高度推崇生育的社会中。因此，那些没有孩子且不想生育的人实际上是在逆潮流而动。人们常常对无子女者（尤其是女性）抱有一些常见的刻板印象，比如认为她们自私、以自我为中心、只关心事业、没有责任、手头宽裕却讨厌孩子，还可能在日后为自己的决定后悔。这些确实是非常普遍的刻板印象。我们对此进行了研究，
we sort of developed a very mini-stereotype scale and looked at that stereotype scale. some of our research. And we found that men, people without a college degree and people who have or want children often hold more negative views of child-free people. So they're more likely to endorse some of these stereotypes. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill for burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply.
我们开发了一个微型刻板印象量表，并利用该量表开展了部分研究。结果发现，男性、没有大学学历的人以及已经生育或想要孩子的人，往往对无子女者持有更多负面看法。也就是说，他们更有可能认同这些刻板印象。您的夏天现在开始，来家得宝（The Home Depot）享受阵亡将士纪念日特惠吧。是时候用 Nextgrill 四火眼燃气烧烤炉开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。还可以用仅售 499 美元的 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐饮组合，整季招待亲友。在这个阵亡将士纪念日，来家得宝享受低价保证。库存有限，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，特定条款适用。
See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. What got you and your husband interested in this particular line of research? And dare I ask, are you child-free? It's a great question. And so we were interested in this line of research, in part, because there's a lot of talk about declining fertility rates in the United States and around the world. And at the same time, we were recognizing that people are more open about their choices, not having kids. And we wanted to understand these child-free people better, especially since I'm not commonly included in academic research. And we knew that there was a lot of studies out there, really good qualitative studies,
详情请访问 Home Depot.com 上的价格匹配页面。是什么让您和您的丈夫对这个特定的研究方向产生兴趣？恕我冒昧，您自己是丁克（无子女）吗？这是一个很好的问题。我们之所以对这个研究方向感兴趣，部分原因在于美国乃至全球关于生育率下降的讨论非常多。与此同时，我们也注意到人们对不生孩子的选择变得更加坦诚。我们希望能更好地了解这些无子女者，尤其是因为他们通常不常被纳入学术研究中。我们知道过去有很多非常优秀的定性研究，
really focused on looking at child-free people's experiences. So a lot of those studies used interview techniques and talked with folks about their experiences, but there were fewer quantitative studies with large representative samples. And in particular, a lot of the large representative studies had lumped child-free adults in with these other categories of non-parents that we talked about earlier. So people who are planning to have kids in the future, people who were childless, who really wanted to have kids. And those groups are so different that we really wanted to do quantitative research that focused more explicitly on child-free adults. And my husband and I don't have kids, but we typically try not to focus on our own status.
这些研究主要聚焦于探讨无子女者的生活经历。其中许多研究采用了访谈法，与人们探讨他们的经历，但具有大样本量的定量研究相对较少。特别是，许多大型代表性研究将无子女成年人与我们之前讨论过的其他非父母群体混为一谈。例如那些计划在未来生孩子的人，以及非常渴望有孩子但尚未生育的人。这些群体之间存在很大差异，因此我们非常希望开展一项更明确聚焦于无子女成年人的定量研究。我和丈夫没有孩子，但我们通常尽量不把焦点放在我们自己的状态上。
We really want to kind of keep the focus on the research itself rather than on this. That makes perfect sense. One of your most recent studies looked at how child-free people felt about where they lived, and you found that they were less satisfied with their neighborhoods than parents were. Why was that? Yeah, so this is a really interesting finding. My husband is by training an urban sociologist, so he's oftentimes really interested in these questions of neighborhood satisfaction. And so we found repeatedly in May 2020 and in April 2020,
我们真的希望把重点放在研究本身，而不是这上面。这完全可以理解。你们最近的一项研究探讨了无子女者对居住地的感受，发现他们对社区的满意度低于父母。这是为什么呢？是的，这是一个非常有趣的发现。我的丈夫受过专业训练，是一位城市社会学家，因此他经常对这类社区满意度的问题表现出浓厚的兴趣。我们反复发现，在 2020 年 5 月和 2020 年 4 月，
22, that child-free people and couples without children were less satisfied with their neighborhoods than parents. And we can think of two explanations for this. One is sort of a, what we would call a warmth explanation. So people could be less satisfied with their neighborhood when they're child-free because they're living with lots of other parents. And we know from some of our other research that parents tend to feel much warmer towards other parents. which could indirectly lead child-free people to feel like they're being excluded from neighborhood activities. So if I live in a neighborhood, the majority of my neighborhood are parents, those parents might have social events that are really focused around children.
呃，22 年，无子女者和无子女夫妇对社区的满意度低于父母。我们可以对此做出两种解释。第一种我们可以称之为“温暖度解释”。也就是说，当无子女者生活在周围有很多父母的社区时，他们对社区的满意度可能会较低。从我们的其他研究中得知，父母往往对其他父母感到更加亲近，这可能会间接导致无子女者觉得自己在社区活动中被边缘化了。如果我住在一个社区里，大多数邻居都是父母，这些父母的社交活动可能会非常围绕着孩子展开。
I might not get invited to those. It might make me feel less integrated into the neighborhood. Another explanation, though, is what we would call our planning explanation. So in April 2022, we serve. both Michigan policymakers and the general Michigan public. And we asked them, when neighborhoods are being designed, whose needs should be prioritized? And in both of those populations,
我可能不会被邀请参加这些活动，这会让我觉得融入社区的程度降低了。不过，另一种解释可以称为“规划解释”。因此，在 2022 年 4 月，我们对密歇根州的政策制定者和密歇根州普通公众进行了调查。我们问他们，在规划社区时，应该优先考虑谁的需求？在这两个群体中，
the preferences of children and parents were prioritized by Michigan policymakers that we surveyed and by the general Michigan public over couples without children. So we had them sort of rank order. We had children and families. We had, you know, empty nester kind of retired folks. And we had, you know, couples of children, couples of that children were always sort of at the bottom of the list in terms of priority.
在我们调查的密歇根州政策制定者以及普通公众看来，儿童和父母的偏好都优先于无子女夫妇。因此，我们让他们进行排序。我们有儿童和家庭，有空巢老人或退休人员，还有无子女夫妇。在优先级方面，无子女夫妇总是排在名单的倒数第一。
And so it could be that planners are not really taking into account the needs of child-free adults when they're planning neighborhoods. And, you know, the general public also kind of agrees with that perspective. What would constitute an ideal child-free neighborhood? I'm just kind of wondering if one were to plan. And since this is something that your husband thinks about, if you talked about, you don't need like swings and a slide, but what do you need for a child-free neighborhood?
因此，这可能是因为规划者在规划社区时并没有真正考虑到无子女成年人的需求，而且广大公众某种程度上也同意这种观点。什么样的社区才算得上是理想的无子女社区？我只是有点好奇，如果要进行规划的话——既然这是你丈夫经常思考的问题，你们是否讨论过——可能不需要秋千和滑梯之类的设施，但一个无子女社区到底需要什么呢？
Yeah, I think that child-free individuals might want, you know, spaces that are similar in some ways to what parents want. They may still want green spaces and parks, but maybe less prioritized around playground. They may want a more active nightlife or things that they can do out. And they may want events that are sort of not always centered around children. So, you know, a lot of events that the neighborhoods hold might be kind of more focused on children, given that the population, most people have kids.
是的，我认为无子女个人可能需要的空间，在某些方面与父母想要的东西相似。他们可能仍然想要绿地和公园，但可能较少以游乐场为中心。他们可能希望有更活跃的夜生活或丰富的外出活动。他们希望举办的活动不总是以儿童为中心。你看，社区举办的许多活动可能更侧重于儿童，因为人口结构中大多数人都有孩子。
Child-free folks might want some events that are more adult focused in their neighborhoods. Have you found that child-free adults tend to live in more urban areas than people with kids? That's a great question. We haven't looked at that in our research, but I would venture to guess that you would probably find more child-free people in urban areas than in rural or suburban areas. What might be some of the policy and societal changes you think could make a difference in supporting child-free adults and countering some of the stigma? Yeah, so I think just recognizing in policy that child-free adults make up a large percent of the population, like in our research we were finding about a quarter of the folks in Michigan were identifying as child-free, I think just even that recognition that they are a constituent group would help quite a bit and that they may have different needs from parents and children that should be considered in policymaking. I also think that policymakers and just the general public, the more that we can sort of destigmatize being child-free, that we can discuss that this is a normal decision that people can make. So I think the lack of visibility around child-free people in our communities is difficult. It seems like a pretty big but sort of hidden group that there's just still this kind of expectation that people are going to have kids.
无子女群体可能希望在社区里有一些更多面向成年人的活动。你们是否发现无子女成年人倾向于住在城市地区，而不是有孩子的家庭？这是一个好问题。我们在研究中没有探讨这一点，但我敢猜测，你可能会在城市地区发现比在农村或郊区更多的无子女者。您认为哪些政策和社会的改变能够在支持无子女成年人和消除部分污名化方面发挥作用？是的，我认为仅在政策层面承认无子女成年人占人口的很大比例就很重要，比如在我们的研究中，我们发现密歇根州大约四分之一的人自认为无子女。我认为，仅仅承认他们是一个需要被代表的群体，就会有很大帮助，而且他们在制定政策时应被纳入考量，因为他们的需求可能与父母和儿童不同。我也认为，政策制定者和广大公众越是能够消除无子女状态的污名化，我们就越能讨论这是一个人们可以做出的正常决定。因此，我认为社区中缺乏无子女者的可见度是一个难题。这似乎是一个规模不小却有些隐蔽的群体，社会上仍然普遍存在一种“人们迟早要生孩子”的期望。
So sometimes there's not as much of a realization that there's this group of people out there that don't want to have kids. And I do think in terms of sort of reproductive rights, that's another spot where it's very important in our country. There's been an erosion of reproductive rights. And that could be very harmful to people. who have made the decision that they don't want to have children if they don't have access to reproductive care. A lot of parents feel that there are ways in which policies in the U.S. don't support their needs. For example, around parental leave or childcare for working parents,
因此，有时人们并没有意识到社会上存在着这样一群不想要孩子的人。我认为，在生殖权利方面，这也是我国非常重要的另一个领域。生殖权利近年来受到了侵蚀。如果无法获得生殖保健，这可能会对那些已经决定不想要孩子的群体造成极大的伤害。许多父母觉得美国的某些政策并没有支持他们的需求，例如工作父母的育儿假或托儿服务，
does it have to feel like a zero-sum game or other ways to create policies that support both parents and non-parents? Yeah, I hope it's not a zero-sum game. I think that we do need support structures in place for parents, too, including things like parental leave. And I don't think we, I feel like pitting kind of us against them as some of the, as resulted in some of the issues of like stigma, stigma and stereotyping that we might see between these two groups. So I think that we can still have all of the kind of policies in place to support parents, which are important, but also can consider that there may be policies that would be helpful. to child-free people as well. So when we think about leave policies,
这必须是一场零和博弈吗？还是有其他方法来制定既支持父母又支持非父母的政策？是的，我希望这不是一场零和博弈。我认为我们也确实需要为父母建立支持结构，包括育儿假等政策。我不觉得我们应该把“我们”对立于“他们”，这种对立导致了我们在两类群体之间看到的污名化和刻板印象等问题。因此，我认为我们既可以保留所有支持父母的重要政策，同时也可以考虑制定对无子女群体同样有帮助的政策。因此，当我们考虑休假政策时，
even being more inclusive about leave policies, so there might be, you know, parental leave, but maybe we want to expand to family leave so that if someone has a parent that they need to take care of, an elderly parent, that affects child-free people as well, that we have this sort of more expansive view of what supports might need to be in place for things like work-life balance.
甚至让休假政策更具包容性——比如除了育儿假，我们或许可以将其扩展为家庭假，以便当有人需要照顾年迈的父母时也能享受假期。这同样会影响到无子女者。我们需要对工作与生活平衡等问题所需的支持建立更广阔的视角。
Is there any research on child-free adults outside the United States? I mean, I would imagine that there are a lot of cultural factors and other pressures that would vary by country. Are there any trends you're seeing, say, in the U.S. that are mirrored anywhere else in the world? Yeah, so we're seeing a rise in child-free adults, or at least more reporting of child-free adults in lots of different countries. And there are researchers looking at the child-free population in lots of different countries. In our own work, we've been trying to expand to other countries. We recently wrote a paper on Japan. Japan has a very low fertility rate.
有没有关于美国以外无子女成年人的研究？我的意思是，我想不同国家之间一定存在很多文化因素和其他压力。您是否看到美国的一些趋势在世界其他地方也有所体现？是的，我们看到无子女成年人在不断增加，或者至少在许多不同的国家，关于无子女成年人的报道越来越多了。许多不同国家的学者都在研究无子女群体。在我们自己的工作中，我们一直试图将研究范围扩展到其他国家。我们最近写了一篇关于日本的论文。日本的生育率非常低，
It's been a concern for their government for quite some time. And so they have very good government data on fertility rates that goes back over time and is publicly available. And they do ask questions that allow for the distinction of child-free adults from other types of non-parents in this data. And in a recently published paper, we looked at over 250,000 Japanese adults and estimated that over 5.5% of adults in Japan are about 2.5 million people were child-free in 2020. That we could see actually, because the data goes back, that that percentage has been increasing since 20. 2000. And Japanese women, singles, and younger people are more likely to identify as child free in that population. So a little bit different from our Michigan population men are more likely to identify in Japan. It's the women that are more likely to identify as child free.
长期以来一直令其政府担忧。因此，他们拥有历时久远且公开可查的非常好的政府生育率数据。在该数据中，他们确实提出了能够将无子女成年人与其他类型非父母区分开来的问题。在最近发表的一篇论文中，我们调查了超过 25 万名日本成年人，估计在 2020 年，日本有超过 5.5% 的成年人——大约 250 万人——是无子女的。通过回溯数据，我们可以发现这一比例自 2000 年以来一直在上升。在日本群体中，女性、单身人士和年轻人更有可能自认无子女。这与我们的密歇根州人群略有不同，在美国是男性更有可能这样认为，但在日本，女性更有可能自认无子女。
So, you know, we've been looking at Japan. We also recently started looking at the Philippines, which is another country that there's been some interest in the media on child-free folks in the Philippines. So we were kind of interested in looking at that group along with a collaborator in the Philippines. And we found that the percentage of single women who are child-free is risen pretty dramatically from 4% to about 10% between 2013 and 22. So there's definitely work going on in other countries. and we're seeing similar trends in other countries where we're seeing potential increases and a decent-sized population. It varies.
所以，我们一直在研究日本。我们最近还开始研究菲律宾，这也是另一个在媒体上引发对无子女群体关注的国家。因此，我们与菲律宾的一位合作者一起，对这个群体产生了兴趣。我们发现，在 2013 年到 2022 年间，无子女单身女性的比例从 4% 显著上升到了约 10%。因此，其他国家确实也在开展相关研究，我们在其他国家也看到了类似的趋势，即无子女比例潜在上升且拥有相当规模的人口。具体情况各不相同，
The prevalence rates vary quite a bit, but we're kind of seeing upticks. Are you lobbying for changes in the way that data are collected? I mean, like government surveys, for example, don't differentiate between people who are just childless for many reasons versus people who consciously decide to be child-free. Yeah, I think it would be worthwhile. I think in some of our research, we've really talked about the types of questions that can be used to identify child-free folks. So you've got questions about whether people want to have kids, questions about people's ideal number of kids, and questions about whether they expect or intend to have kids in the future. those are three different types of questions that can be asked that it could be used to distinguish
普及率存在相当大的差异，但我们确实看到了上升趋势。你们是否在游说改变数据收集的方式？我的意思是，比如政府调查并没有区分那些因各种原因没有孩子的人，与那些有意识决定不要孩子的人。是的，我认为这是值得做的。在我们的某些研究中，我们确实讨论了可用于识别无子女群体的各种问题类型。比如询问人们是否想要孩子的问题、关于人们理想子女数量的问题，以及关于他们未来是否期望或打算生孩子的问题。这是可以提出的三种不同类型的问题，可用于区分
child-free folks. If you use those three different types of questions, you get slightly different answers in terms of the prevalence of child-free individuals. We think that questions about the want or desire to have kids are probably the ideal way to ask because it sort of gets up the core of the definition of what a child-free person is or a person who does not want to have kids. And so I think having those types of questions on government surveys would be helpful because it would help to identify and distinguish child-free individuals and from other types of non-parents and you'd get a more fine-grained view of non-parents in those surveys. What are the next big questions you're looking to answer?
无子女群体。如果使用这三种不同类型的问题，在无子女个体的普及率方面会得出略有不同的答案。我们认为，关于生育意愿或渴望的问题可能是最理想的提问方式，因为它触及了“无子女者”或“不想要孩子的人”这一定义的本质。因此，我认为在政府调查中加入这些类型的问题会很有帮助，因为这有助于识别和区分无子女个体与其他类型的非父母，从而在这些调查中获得对非父母群体更细致的视角。你们接下来想要解答的重大问题是什么？
Yeah. So we have several questions. that we're interested in right now. So one of them is really expanding out to other countries. So being able to look more carefully at prevalence rates in other countries and expanding to the U.S. more nationally. So being able to kind of get a better view of the prevalence rate across the United States using population representative samples.
是的。我们现在对几个问题很感兴趣。其中之一就是真正将研究扩展到其他国家。能够更仔细地观察其他国家的普及率，并将研究扩展到全美范围。从而利用具有人口代表性的样本，更好地了解全美的普及率。
But we're also interested in some other questions. We're interested. we've been working a little with Jay Zygmont, who is a financial advisor for child-free folks. And one thing that we're interested in that we're sort of collecting data on right now is really that the special needs that child-free individuals might have in terms of finances. They are distinct from parents in a lot of way in terms of what they will need for their finances when they get older. So I'm really kind of looking at that a bit and some survey work. And I think we're also really interested. You mentioned that I do network research.
但我们也对其他一些问题感兴趣。我们一直在与专为无子女群体提供服务的财务规划师杰伊·齐格蒙特（Jay Zygmont）进行一些合作。我们目前正在收集数据的其中一个感兴趣的领域，确实是无子女个体在财务方面可能拥有的特殊需求。他们在变老时所需的财务支持方面，在许多方面与父母截然不同。因此，我确实正在通过一些问卷调查来深入研究这一点。我也认为我们真的很感兴趣——你提到过我从事网络研究，
So I'm really, one of my fantasies is to be able to combine my work on networks with looking at the child-free population. So really being able to look to see our child-free individuals' networks different from parents and in what ways. And I anticipate that there are some differences in their social networks. And we'd really be interested to see, like, do you do you? Child-free people tend to have mostly other child-free friends, or are they friends with parents as well? And are they more socially isolated, especially at certain ages where maybe activities are really focused around children for a lot of the population?
所以，我的梦想之一就是能够将我的网络研究工作与无子女群体的研究结合起来。真正去看看无子女者的社会网络与父母有什么不同，以及在哪些方面不同。我预计他们的社会网络确实存在一些差异。我们真的很想知道，比如，无子女的人是否倾向于主要和同样无子女的朋友交往，还是他们也和有父母的朋友交往？他们是否更加社交孤立，特别是在某些年龄段，可能对许多人来说，生活的大部分活动都围绕着孩子展开？
So those are some of the questions we've been interested in addressing. Well, that sounds really fascinating, and I hope you succeed in your research going forward. I want to thank you for joining me today, Dr. Neal. Thank you. It's been a pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.spokenof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
这就是我们一直致力于解答的一些问题。嗯，听起来非常引人入胜，我希望您接下来的研究能够顺利。尼尔博士，非常感谢您今天能来参加节目。谢谢您，我也很高兴能来。您可以在我们的网站 www.spokenof psychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 以及各大播客平台上收听《心理学话语》往期的节目。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请订阅并给我们留下评价。如果您对未来的播客节目有任何建议或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Warnerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychology. Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学话语》由李·沃纳曼（Lee Warnerman）制作。感谢您的收听，我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。